- Hi, good evening, everyone.
I'm Priya Natarajan,
the current director
of the Franke Program.
I'm an astrophysicist,
and I'm a faculty member
in the departments of physics
and astronomy at Yale.
I am deeply invested in
interdisciplinary scholarship
as you've probably guessed.
And thanks to my academic training
and a sort of an intellectual interest
in the history and philosophy of science.
I'm very fortunate to be
leading the Franke Program
which is the flagship
cross-disciplinary program at Yale.
First, I would like to start
by recognizing the generosity
and support of our benefactors,
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke
for all they do for us and for Yale.
I'm delighted that they're
going to be joining us today.
First, I would also like to remind you too
that we are recording this event,
and that all participants must
therefore mute their videos.
If you wish you can submit
your questions after the talk
through the chat feature.
Our speaker this evening
is one of our own brilliant scholars,
Professor Alan Mikhail,
Professor of History
and the current chair of the
Department of History at Yale.
Alan is a preeminent historian
of the early modern Muslim world,
the Ottoman empire and Egypt.
His research and teaching focuses mostly
on the history of
empires and environments,
both matters that are incredibly
important to understand
beyond the confines of academia
as we all venture to make sense
of today's complex globally interconnected
and yet fractured world,
rife with inequities of
opportunity, health and wealth
and the looming climate catastrophe
brought by uncurtailed human
activities over history
and their damaging impact
on the environment.
He received his PhD
from the University of
California, Berkeley
where his dissertation
won the Malcolm Kerr Award
of the Middle East Studies Association
and Berkeley's own James Kepner award.
He was a member of the Andrew
Mann Fellowship of Scholars
in the humanities and was
at Stanford University
before coming to Yale in 2010.
He's the author of many acclaimed books,
the first of which "The
Animal in Ottoman Egypt"
came out in 2014,
"Nature and Empire in Ottoman Egypt:
"an Environmental History"
that came out in 2011.
He's also the editor
of "Water on Sand: Environmental Histories
"of the Middle East and North Africa."
So his articles, research
articles, have appeared
in all the eminent journals
across disciplines.
And he's the recipient of
many awards and honors.
In the interest of time,
I will just mention a few:
the Roger Owen Award of the
Middle East Studies Association,
the Alice Hamilton prize
of the American Society
for Environmental History,
the Wayne Rasmussen Prize
of the Agricultural History Society,
and the Yale's Gustav Ranis
and Samuel and Ronnie Heyman prizes.
He teaches undergraduate
and graduate courses
in the history of the
early modern Muslim world
and the Mediterranean, the Ottoman empire
and environmental history.
So before I hand over to him,
I just wanted to remind you
of a few upcoming Frankie Program events.
We have the author and
science communicator,
Ainissa Ramirez, former
Yale faculty member
giving a talk on April 20th at 4:00 p.m.
And we have the Inference
Project Colloquium
by the philosopher Lorenzo
Magnani on April 22nd.
And then we have Lyanda Lynn Haupt,
the author of "Mozart's Starling"
who will be speaking to us on April 27th.
So we have a full roster for April,
and we also have,
are planning to show
the movie "Coded Bias,"
and have a discussion with
the filmmaker on April 21st.
And so I would also like to remind you all
to look at our two other ongoing projects,
the Learning by Doing
Project on our website
and the inference,
Understanding the Nature
of Inference project.
So now to today's event today.
Today Alan will be talking
to us about his new book,
"God's Shadow: Sultan
Selim, His Ottoman Empire,
"and the Making of the Modern World."
And the title of his talk
is "Columbus and Islam."
And this is an encounter
that I'm extremely excited
and curious to hear about.
Thank you so much, Alan, for
agreeing to speak to us today.
- Thank you, Priya,
very much for having me.
I want to begin by extending my thanks
to you for the invitation,
to Ty and to Guy
for helping to organize today's event.
Thanks to everybody for tuning in
on this afternoon in March.
I wish we could do it in person,
but one day, one day soon.
I'm gonna go ahead and
begin by sharing my screen.
And as I do that, of course,
allow me also to thank the Frankie family
for this lecture series
and for all of their support
of what we do at Yale.
So as Priya said, this talk
is coming out of a book
that I just published that's
really focused on the life
of a particular Ottoman
Sultan, Selim the First
the ninth Sultan of the Ottoman Empire
who lived from 1470 to 1520.
I'm really not gonna be
talking much about him today.
I'm gonna be focusing
in on a part of the book
that addresses part of the
role of the Ottoman Empire
and of other Muslim polities
around the Mediterranean
in the shaping of Columbus.
This is something that I go to,
go in depth into in the book.
So if you, if you're
curious about how this story
fits into a larger story
about the Ottoman Empire
and the early modern world,
I'd encourage you to
take a look at the book.
So two narratives dominate
the story of the conjoining
of the continents of the
old world and the Americas,
peopling and de-peopling,
that is conquest and genocide,
nation building and colonization,
the migration of Europeans
and the forced movement of
enslaved Africans on the one hand
and the displacement and death
of millions of indigenous
Americans on the other.
These are obviously very
familiar narratives,
narratives that work quite well.
Much of the arc of the
story that they tell
is useful for us
in thinking about the history
of the Atlantic world.
And much of it does a
lot of very good work
for our understanding of how we came to be
in this historical moment.
As with any historical framework though,
these grand narratives also
miss some things as well.
So in my talk today
I wanna argue for another grand narrative,
one that I think needs to be
a part of the violent story
of the joining of the
four Atlantic continents.
And that is the role of the confrontation
between Islam and Christendom
in the shaping of this history.
It's an essential part of the
story, I'll try to show today.
It says an essential part of the story
of the colonization of the Americas,
the extension of Europe and
Africa across the ocean.
And it's essential that it be
a part of our understanding
of this history.
Conflict and cooperation
between Islam and Christianity
shaped the history of the Mediterranean,
perhaps more than any other single force.
And this was as true before 1492,
as it was after, some
of which is gestured to
in the quote that's on the screen.
The Europeans who went to the Americas
were in many ways formed by
this geopolitical encounter.
And as I'll discuss, it
remained a salient feature
of their world even on the
other side of the ocean.
Indeed one could tell a continuous story
of the role of Islam in
the shaping of the history
of the Americas from 1492 to the present.
This is a story that involves
slavery, piracy, trade,
the captivity of Europeans
in the Muslim world,
immigration, warfare, cultural
exchange and assimilation.
I won't be able to tell
that full story here today.
Rather I'm focusing obviously
on the very first moment
of this history, the one that
has rightly been freighted
with so much explanatory weight,
in the narratives I mentioned
above, Columbus in 1492.
I will ask how Islam shaped
Columbus and his voyages
and what its role was
in the very early years
of the European colonization
of the Caribbean.
This will be the bulk of my talk today.
And at the end, I'll offer thoughts
about some of the
implications of the story
that I'm telling about Columbus and Islam.
So let me begin the story
then where Columbus began,
and that is in the city of Genoa.
He was born there in 1451.
And even in the small neighborhood
he shared with his
parents and four siblings,
Islam was a presence.
Columbus spent most of the
first two decades of his life
in that neighborhood.
He would have seen or
heard about the many fleets
leaving for Jerusalem on
one of the numerous crusades
that originated in Genoa.
Columbus's city was a magnet for crusaders
owing to the strong presence
of the Knights of St. John
who offered free housing
and medical care to crusaders.
Columbus and his family
likely knew some crusaders,
and he no doubt grew up
hearing of their tales
of distant lands and infidel enemies.
It's important that Columbus
was born just two years before
the Ottoman Sultan Mehmed the Conqueror
took the city of Constantinople.
This the Bellini portrait of Mehmed.
More than any other event,
this conquest shaped the
contours of Columbus's,
and indeed his entire
generation's geopolitical life.
Constant calls for European
crusades against the Ottomans
didn't lead to very
much in the second half
of the 15th century.
Columbus's age was mostly
one of European stasis
in the face of Muslim ascendancy.
In Genoa's San Lorenzo Cathedral,
Columbus went to mass every week.
This church held important treasures,
supposedly captured
during earlier crusades.
An Emerald green bowl said to be the dish
Jesus washed his hands in
before the last supper,
and a silver reliquary
purported to contain the
ashes of John the Baptist.
Such trophies of conquest
were sprinkled all over Europe
from the smallest towns
to the largest cathedrals.
They brought the conflict
between Islam and Christianity
into nearly every European
neighborhood church,
amulets of the looming threat of Islam
that had supposedly been
captured during earlier crusades.
In between Sundays at San Lorenzo,
Columbus would have learned
about other Europeans
who had traveled to the Muslim world.
Even though it was a
vital Crusader entrepôt,
Genoa was above all a mercantile
port not a military one.
Over the centuries the
Genoese merchant families
who ran the city developed
many distant connections.
Colonies of Genoese
merchants prospered in cities
like Beirut, Alexandria,
Tunis, Oran, Algiers,
in Europe in places like Naples,
Paris, London, and so on.
Sometimes these Genoese trading families
even exercised something
akin to political control
in some of these cities,
especially around the Black Sea Coast.
Genoa maintained very old
connections to ports and towns,
ports and towns that would
steadily be incorporated
into the Ottoman Empire in the
14th and the 15th centuries.
In Columbus's youth,
Genoa's merchant community
was growing to be quite
anxious about Ottoman advances
in the Black Sea and the Mediterranean,
and already mourning some of their losses
around the two seas.
In addition--
- [Priya] Alan?
- Yes.
- I had a very quick question.
So was Genoa actually a very
wealthy city at this point?
Or, I mean, so what was
the socioeconomic frame
at this time?
- Sure, Genoa is indeed
quite a wealthy city,
largely based on its trading
connections with the East.
Absolutely.
And you get a sense from
this map of of the expanse
of their trading connections.
So in addition to breathing
in the mercantile air
all around him in Genoa, Columbus
learned important lessons
about the East by reading
the works of various writers,
and in particular, the
work of one other Italian
who had spent time in some
of Genoa's Black Sea cities,
and that's Marco Polo.
Reading the famous tales of Marco polo,
and again, other accounts
of travels to distant lands
helped to form Columbus's
mental canvas as a boy.
One of the most important
things Columbus learned
from Marco Polo was the existence
of a figure known as the
Grand Khan of the East.
Marco supposedly arrived
in the opulent court
of this Grand Khan, far off
in some vague place in Asia,
past Constantinople, Jerusalem,
Baghdad, and Afghanistan,
where he writes
that he discovered a
jewel-encrusted paradise
of luxury, learning, and power.
What most interested Columbus
and other European readers of Marco Polo
was that the Grand Khan was
precisely not a Christian,
but according to Marco
Polo wanted to be one.
Although he had achieved
the heights of civilization
without the benefits of Christianity,
the Grand Khan seemed to understand
the truth of the religion and
might even convert himself,
thereby gaining for Christianity
the souls of all his subjects.
This fantasy of the Grand Khan
and his potential conversion
lit European imaginations.
For Christians he offered
the perfect mirror
of everything Islam should
have been but wasn't,
a civilization no doubt,
one formed outside of the
realm of Christianity,
but one that also recognized
its own bankruptcy
in the face of the
glories of Christianity.
The Grand Khan was thus
not yet a Christian,
but according to the fantasy
was always about to be one.
Moreover, once he entered the faith,
the Muslims of the Middle East
in possession of Jerusalem,
the object of the crusades,
would then be surrounded
by Christians who in one
final apocalyptic pincer move
would destroy Islam forever
to retake the Holy city.
So after centuries of crusades,
with the spectacular growth of the Ottoman
and Mamluk Empires
increasingly blocking access
to trade with the East, Europe
looked with anticipation
to a potentate, thousands of miles away.
Filled with these and other fantasies,
raised on accounts of the
crusades, Columbus's interactions
with Islam deepened
during his teenage years
when he began taking to the Mediterranean
as an apprentice sailor,
embarking on his first maritime voyages
at the age of 13 or 14.
He worked as a merchant's assistant,
packing merchandise onboard ships,
recording weights and costs,
securing lodging in ports
for captain and crew,
and generally being available
to help with navigation
and business matters.
He built a reputation for himself
as a reliable and
efficient sailor for hire
and was able to find endless
opportunities working the sea
for merchant and other expeditions
in the employ of Europe's
many small principalities
and larger polities.
Some of these voyages in his early years
sailing around the Mediterranean
took him to the shores of
both the Ottoman Empire
and to other Muslim States around the sea.
So the map that I'm now showing you
is one that we're quite
accustomed to seeing
about Columbus's sailing
career before the four voyages,
that he was plying off
the course of Portugal
made his way down to West Africa,
which I'll talk about in a moment.
But the section that I'm
about to share with you
is really, even before
this, it's to make the point
that he had a Mediterranean sailing career
before ever crossing through
the Strait of Gibraltar,
and that this is an important
part of understanding Columbus
and his biography, but really crucial
for understanding his connections
with the Muslim world.
So I don't have a map of
his Mediterranean voyages,
but the map that I'm showing
you now has a pre-map
that I'm gonna give to you now in words.
So in 1472, when Columbus
was 21, we have his first,
we have an account of his
first direct encounter
with the Muslim world, the
first one that we know of.
He took a job as a mercenary
sailor for the King of Anjou,
during a war to capture Naples.
Over the course of this fighting,
one of the King's large three-masted ships
was captured and commandeered
to Tunis in North Africa.
The King dispatched Columbus
to sail to North Africa
to bring his ship back.
Tunis in those years was the stronghold
of the Hafsid Empire,
an empire that ruled along much
of the coast of North Africa
that made much of its money from piracy
and also from the overland
caravan trade along the coast
and then also along the Sahara.
Like other city States
around the Mediterranean,
whether in Italy or other
parts of North Africa,
the Hafsid Empire made a lot of money
and was able to put that
money towards great arts,
culture and patronage.
Intrepid youth that he was,
Columbus charged with retrieving
the King's ship sailed,
excitedly he tells us, with
his more apprehensive crew
from Naples first to
Sardinia to rest and resupply
and then turned south to North Africa
to attempt to retrieve the ship.
We don't know the outcome of this venture.
We don't know if the ship
was retrieved or not.
Columbus doesn't mention
that he retrieved the ship.
One might presume that if he
had he would have mentioned it.
Despite the uncertainties
though in the historical record,
this earliest encounter of Columbus
with the world of Islam
was his first opportunity
to test the stories
that he had heard about
in his youth about crusades,
the stories he'd heard at
church, from reading Marco Polo,
his first opportunity
to test these stories
against the reality of the
awesome power of a Muslim state,
in this case, the Hafsid Empire.
He experienced firsthand the naval power
of the rulers of Tunis to
capture and hold the King's ship.
His account that he writes after the fact
describes the fear that
he saw in his crew's eyes
when they realized they
would have to sail south
into enemy territory,
presumably outmatched and out manned.
Sailing to Tunis in his early twenties
thus was an opportunity to test
the mythologies of his youth
against the power of Muslim
States around the Mediterranean.
He would gain closer
and much more profound
firsthand experience of the Muslim world
a couple years later when in
1475 a family firm in Genoa,
the Spinolas, sent him to Chios,
the hilly Island of
mostly scrub vegetation
in the Aegean Sea, just
off the Anatolian shore.
Chios famous for its mastic.
This is the mastic tree,
and then the mastic sap
that was used in cooking
and medicines of all kinds.
Genoa lost its colony in Crimea
in the northern Black Sea,
its last outpost on the Black Sea in 1475,
just a few months in fact
before Columbus went to Chios that year.
So Chios when Columbus arrived there,
represented Genoa's eastern most territory
in the Mediterranean and the Black Sea,
and was therefore of vital commercial
and strategic interests.
This is a rendition of the ports of Chios.
In traveling to Chios,
Columbus was exposed
for the very first time
to the awesome power
of the Ottoman Empire.
Although the Island was
still a Genoese colony,
it was very much in the Ottoman's orbit.
They ruled the blue seas around the island
and all the ports of call on the coast
just across the narrow straits
that separated the island
from mainland Anatolia.
The Ottomans had captured
other major Aegean islands
over the previous two decades,
places like Imbros,
Lemnos, Lesbos, Samothrace,
and Columbus was regaled when in Chios
with tales of dread and horror
about the Ottoman conquest
of Caffa in Crimea,
again just a few months
before he arrived there,
and even more so of the
conquest of Constantinople
almost two decades earlier.
The memory of the loss of
Constantinople in particular
was very fresh on the island of Chios,
even over 20 years later.
The Genoese sent many
reinforcements from Chios,
the closest of the
Italian State's outposts
to Constantinople,
and this contingent suffered heavy losses
that affected almost
every family on Chios.
So the stories Columbus
learned in his youth
of Christianity's crusades with Islam
were suddenly brought to life for him.
When he met and heard from
the relatives of others
who had actually fought
against the awesome power
of the Ottomans in their
conquest of Constantinople.
Here on the Eastern front of Christendom,
he witnessed the awesome
power of the Ottoman Empire.
He saw that it surrounded
a tiny island like Chios,
that it might very well
continue its march west,
perhaps even into Europe itself.
Like other islands, the
majority of Chios was Greek,
but there was a growing Turkish
population there as well.
Columbus heard on the
island about Constantinople
and other losses around the
Black Sea and in the Aegean,
bringing home to him again the idea
that Christianity had to be
boldly offensive against Islam
or risk further losses to the Ottomans
and other Muslim powers.
After his time in the
employ of the Spinolas
and his time in Chios,
Columbus eventually makes
his way to Portugal.
There he fell in with
the group of explorers
that the famous Portuguese
Prince Henry the Navigator
had assembled before his death.
Like many ambitious Europeans,
these Portuguese adventurers
were looking for ways
around the Muslim world.
They also believed in
the truth of crusade.
Like Columbus they had heard tales
of the Grand Khan of the
East and were interested
in trying to find a path
towards the Grand Khan.
They were indeed quite explicit
in defining many of their
expeditions in religious terms,
as part of a global crusade
between Christendom and Islam.
For example, according to one
of Henry's contemporaries,
writing in that fateful
year 1453, Henry quote
"was actuated by the zeal for God,
"by the disease desire for Alliance
"with the Eastern Christians
of the Grand Khan,
"by an eagerness to know how far the power
"of the infidel existed, by
the wish to convert people
"to Christianity and by the
desire to fight the Moors."
Henry's most famous plan
to outflank the Muslims
of the Mediterranean rested on his belief
in a Southern route around Africa,
and he and his explorers
spent much of their time
playing along the West African coast.
It was to their utter terror and dismay
when working their way South
along the African coast,
they discovered that Islam
was already flourishing
in many parts of West Africa.
By the time the Portuguese arrived,
Islam had grown from a minority
faith of a few adherents
to the official state religion
of several West African empires,
most prominent among them
the Mali empire that had adopted Islam
as its official religion in 1324.
In the 15th century when
these Portuguese explorers
were sailing along the coast,
the presence of Muslims
in West Africa further deepened the sense
among European Christian
Christian crusaders
that their faith was
somehow surrounded by Islam
and that some drastic action
was needed to attempt to defend
against this further spread.
As they continued sailing
south along the African coast,
the farthest point they reached
was the port city of São Jorge da Mina,
what is known today as Elmina in Ghana.
This city would prove a
linchpin of Portugal's empire
in West Africa, a key conduit
for funneling first gold
and later slaves from
West Africa to Portugal
and then eventually elsewhere as well.
In 1481, Portugal's new King João II
resolved that his kingdom
needed a stronger presence
on the Gulf of Guinea to protect
its growing economic stakes
in the gold trade.
And so he dispatched ahead
a heavily armed fleet
with building materials
to this trading post
of São Jorge da Mina to
construct a fortress.
On 10 caravels and two transport ships,
foundation stones, roof
tiles, nails, provisions,
all were sent, and the
structure that was constructed
was one of the first European buildings
constructed in Sub-Saharan Africa.
Of course, many men were
sent on these 12 ships
to help with the construction
and to deal with any business matters.
And Columbus was on one of these
12 ships, now 30 years old.
When he arrives in Elmina,
Columbus brings together
three pieces of very crucial information
that concretize the idea that
he had been thinking about
for quite a while now, the idea
of a Western route to Asia.
In West Africa, he found
seemingly endless supplies
of precious gold, the gold coast.
Contemporary understandings
of geography taught Columbus
that regions at the same
latitude enjoyed similar climates
and natural features.
So in his understanding, if he
was to head directly due West
from Elmina, he would
find lands rich in gold.
Gold was important to him
to help to build the army
that he needed for the
reconquest of Jerusalem.
The second piece of information
that Columbus learned in
Elmina was that Asia was close.
Sailors in the African city told him
that logs regularly washed up on shore
that seemed to have been
worked by human hands.
Evidence that the lands across the ocean
from whence this worked
wood supposedly came
could not have been very far away at all.
The third piece of information
that he learned in Elmina
had to do with the Atlantic's
currents and wind patterns.
The prevailing current
off the West African coast
flows out to sea which
is the exact opposite
of the situation in Portugal
where the eastward currents
made it difficult to sail West
for most of the year.
So to head West from Iberia then,
it made sense to first sail
South along the African coast
to pick up the westerly
current across the ocean.
From Elmina Columbus returned to Iberia,
confident that he understood
now how to execute his plan
to sail across the ocean to
find Asia, the Grand Khan,
to surround the Muslims of the Middle East
and eventually to conquer Jerusalem.
The thing that he most needed
at this point was a patron.
The story of Columbus's
back and forth negotiations
between various European sovereigns
to secure patronage is
a very, very famous one
that I won't get into now.
What I want to emphasize though,
and what has not been
remarked upon is the role
that the Ottomans and other Muslims played
in this affair of seeking patronage.
Columbus's major push for the money
that he needed for his voyages occurred
during the late 1480s.
This was the same decade in
which the eventual financiers
of his voyages, the second
cousins Isabella and Ferdinand
had declared their war
against Islam in Iberia.
And it's not a coincidence
that Europe's war on Islam
in Iberia and elsewhere and
Columbus's voyages occurred
at almost exactly the same time.
In Columbus's mind, in the
mind of the Spanish sovereigns,
these were two pieces
of what they interpreted
as a millennial war between
Christianity and Islam.
As part of a global
strategy against Islam,
the Spanish moved their navies East
in the Mediterranean
against the Ottomans' other Muslim powers,
endeavored to push out
all of Iberia's Muslims,
and sent Columbus off to the West
to try to surround the
Muslims of the Middle East.
Ottoman advances in the second
half of the 15th century
directly impacted Spanish
holdings in the Mediterranean.
Mehmed the conqueror,
the conqueror of Constantinople,
captured the strategic strategic
walled port city of Otranto
on the very tip of the heel
of the Italian peninsula,
right here Otranto.
He captured this small port in 1480.
From there he sent ships
to the coast of Sicily
to assess a potential
invasion of that island.
Sicily is the largest of
the Mediterranean's island,
once a Muslim possession, of course,
but in the 15th century was
under the nominal sovereignty
of Ferdinand and Isabella of Spain.
And so a threatening move by the Ottomans
demanded the Spanish King
and Queen's attention.
Ottoman rule over a place like Sicily
would have solidified their control
of the entire Eastern
half of the Mediterranean.
Again, think of Genoa being
pushed out of the Black Sea,
being steadily pushed out of the Aegean.
And now the Ottomans
pushing even further West,
potentially all the way to Sicily.
Were the Ottomans to hold Sicily,
this would give them a launching pad
for invasions further West in the sea.
Sicily is very much the
midway point of the sea
and was of much concern of the Ottoman,
of the Spanish sovereigns.
So much so that one of
Isabella's court chroniclers
wrote quote, "Every day news
came to the King and Queen
"that the Turks had a
great Armada on the sea
"and that they were sending it to conquer
"the kingdom of Sicily."
The Spanish sovereigns leaped into action,
sending a fleet to defend Sicily.
Luckily for them though Mehmed
died the next year in 1481.
And the Ottoman succession
crisis forced the empire
to give up on Sicily, to give up Otronto,
and indeed to withdraw
from Italy altogether,
and they would never
gain any other territory
on the Italian peninsula after that.
Despite this retreat though,
over the course of the 1480s,
the Ottomans continued to push West
in the Mediterranean
testing Spain's resolve
and the resolve of other European powers.
In 1488, Mehmed's son and
successor Bayezid attacked Malta.
This prompted Spain again
to send reinforcements
to strengthen its garrisons in Sicily.
Again, Malta very close
to Sicily as you see here.
Between 1487 and the middle of the 1490s,
Ottoman ships made
landings even further West
reaching all the way to Corsica,
Pisa, the Baelaric Islands,
and North African ports
just across from the
Iberian mainland itself.
These were not full-scale
military invasions,
did not result in any sort of
lasting Ottoman settlements,
but nevertheless, the
sight of Ottoman ships
forcibly pulling in to harbor
panicked already
frightened European States.
The force of the Ottomans
seemed to be all over the sea.
These gains in the
Mediterranean against Spain
and other European interests
made the already precarious
position of Spain's Muslims
much more dire.
These internal Muslims in
Iberia were lumped together
with Spain's external Muslim enemies.
Like Columbus, Henry, the Pope,
Isabella considered it her
duty to crusade against Muslims
wherever they may be.
Within Iberia there were Muslims
both living under Spanish Christian rule
and small Muslim States in the south,
independent states in the south.
Both were liable allies of the
Ottomans and other Muslims,
according to Isabella and Ferdinand.
So given the Ottoman's territorial
expansion in the 1480s,
Isabella and Ferdinand saw
their Reconquista in the South,
their war against the Muslims in the south
not simply as a process of
local political consolidation
on the Iberian peninsula,
but rather as one piece of what they saw
as a global civilizational war.
Interpreted by them
and by other Christians
as the first step in rolling back Islam
and its representative states
from the Mediterranean,
and if they had their way eventually
from the face of the earth altogether.
Steeped his entire life in
the rhetoric and reality
of the crusades, Columbus used his belief
in the notion of a war
between Christendom and Islam
to push his case for the Atlantic voyages
with Isabella and Ferdinand.
If he could show them that
heading West across the ocean
would help to defeat
Islam, then he thought
they might be more liable
to finance his journey.
Columbus found it very
difficult to get any traction
with the sovereigns in this period.
They were really too busy with their Wars
to pay him any attention.
In the late 1480s, Ferdinand
and Isabella were fighting
in the south, and the
Reconquista was quite successful
in these years.
The famous surrender
of Granada, of course,
on January 2nd, 1492, legally
ended over seven centuries
of Muslim rule on the Iberian peninsula.
For Christians everywhere,
not just in Spain,
Granada represented a
monumental victory over Islam.
Church bells rang out
across European cities.
The Pope ordered a day of festivities.
Celebratory bull fights
were organized across Spain.
Mock reenactments of the siege
of Granada were played out
across European towns.
Coming just a few decades after
the loss of Constantinople,
Granada was for many in
Europe an act of retribution,
a Christian answer
to the most powerful
Muslim empire on earth.
In the words of one
Spanish court historian,
the Conquest of Granada quote
"was famed and celebrated
"through all the realms of Christendom,
"and it extended to the
farthest and most remote lands
"of the Turk and the Sultan."
After the fall of
Granada in January, 1492,
Isabella, against the
judgment of her advisors
and her husband, emboldened
by her recent victories,
agreed to fund Columbus's
journey across the Atlantic.
She had just vanquished
Spain's Muslim kingdoms,
a first step she thought in her global war
against Christianity's ultimate enemy.
Christ would March upon the world.
Jerusalem would be won.
If Columbus's plan, risky
and farfetched as it was,
could contribute in even a minor way
to the destruction of Islam,
then it would have proved
more than a worthy investment
of the Queen's resources.
The opening lines of Columbus's log book
on his first foray across
the Atlantic make plain
that he understood his
voyage as a new crusade
in centuries of war between
Islam and Christendom.
In the space of just a single sentence,
Columbus pivoted from Spain's Reconquista
to finding and converting the Grand Khan
Marco Polo had promised and to
surrounding therefore Islam.
The extension of Spain's
civilizational religious crusade
is part of what sends Columbus
off across the Atlantic,
and this is essential to
understanding his voyages.
He sailed off to win Jerusalem.
He sailed off to win
Jerusalem for Christendom.
And this is why the story
that I've relayed to you
of the biography of Columbus's
interactions with Islam
matters so much.
From his earliest days in Genoa
where he waved good tidings to crusaders
to his experience with the
Portuguese enslavement of Muslims
and others in West Africa
to the very moment before
he left Europe in Granada,
Columbus's life was formed
in and against Islam.
So this brings us then to
that fateful moment, to 1492,
that freighted tipping point
of multi-continental
destruction and transformation.
It also brings me to stop
sharing my screen now.
What does the history I've just relayed
of Columbus and Islam
mean for our understanding
of this fateful year?
When turning to the writings
of Columbus and others
in that first generation of conquistadors,
one finds perhaps surprisingly
sparks of Islam flying up
from their pages.
In the Americas where Islam
so very clearly did not exist,
they nevertheless saw it.
As arresting as it may
seem, the Spanish stretched
the analytical limits of their
late 15th century universe
to understand some of the Americas
and its indigenous peoples
as somehow related to Islam.
What do I mean by this?
Let me give some examples.
In his journals, Columbus
refers to the weapons
of the indigenous Tainos in
the Caribbean as el fanjes,
a Spanish word derived from the Arabic
for a curved metal sword
inscribed with Koranic versus
that was commonly used by Muslim soldiers
in battle in Spain.
Despite the fact that
Columbus himself tells us
that the Taino quote "have no iron."
And of course they knew
nothing of the Koran.
He likens them to Muslim soldiers
by putting these swords in his
hands, in their hands, sorry.
Later when Columbus first saw the scarves
of a group of Taino women,
he thought they were somehow
related through trade
or some other form of Eurasian contact
to what he termed Moorish sashes.
A friar named Ramón Pané
who sailed on Columbus's
second voyage in 1494
described Indian singing as
akin to that of the Moors.
A couple decades later, Cortés wrote
that the Aztecs of Mexico
quote "wore Moorish robes,"
that Aztec women quote
"looked like Moorish women."
Aztec dancing he thought
was derived from the dances
of the Moors.
Cortés's encounter with the Aztecs
proved especially fertile for
these kinds of comparisons
between the Islamic civilizations
the Spanish had fought
in the old world and what
they were experiencing
in the new world.
In the Aztecs, Cortés and his men
met a formidable, complex
empire with enormous cities,
one of the largest cities
in the world at the time,
a highly sophisticated political culture,
and imposing armies.
More than, for example, Taino society,
the Spanish saw in the Aztec's arrival
and in the civilization
a kin to their enemies
of the old world, the Muslim
empires of the Mediterranean.
Cortés wrote, for example, that he saw
over 400 mosques, mezquitas,
in what is today in Mexico.
He called Montezuma a Sultan.
He described Montezuma's palaces
in terms strikingly similar
to those of the Muslim palaces of Granada
including claiming to see in Mexico
tiles and roofing that only
existed in Granada at the time.
These things continued long
after Columbus and Cortés.
Over the course of the
16th century, the Spanish,
for example, would try
to subdue and convert
the nomadic Chichimecas of Mexico,
referring to them as árabes, the Arabs.
In Brazil, the children of
Portuguese men and Indian women
were referred to as el
Mamelucos, the Mamluks,
the Mamluk empire based in Cairo.
Plains Indians captured and
transported by the Spanish
as slaves to what is today New Mexico
came to be known as genízaros,
a corruption of the Turkish word
for the Janissaries, yeñiçeri.
The Spanish named a large city
in the Yucatan Grand Cairo.
We could go on and on citing
these kinds of examples.
The city on the US Mexico border today
that's in the news because
of the migrant crisis
is another example, this
Matamoros, Moor Slayer,
the Slayer of the Moors.
On one level there's nothing
surprising about any of this.
The Spanish conquistadors were forged
in an old world crucible of
Christian Muslim violence.
Many of them had fought
against the Muslim kingdoms
of Southern Liberia and North Africa.
Many had encountered Muslims
in West Africa as well.
Many had traded with
Muslim traders in ports
around the Mediterranean.
Grasping for some conceptual framework
through which to reconcile
all of the difference
and the newness they
encountered in the Americas,
they turned to the most
extreme version of otherness
available to them, Islam.
In a new place, fighting new enemies,
they fell back on what
they knew, as we always do.
As John Elliott, one of
the foremost historians
of Cortés notes quote, "Since
the only political model
"for his conquest Cortés
knew was the reconquest,"
the Reconquista,
"Montezuma had to be
treated in his narrative
"as a Muslim ruler would have been.
"Anáhuac in central
Mexico is thus described
"as far as Cortés is able
in images more appropriate
"to Syria or Persia
"than to any possible
American Indian society."
At another level though,
these sparks of Islam
in the historical record
of the early Spanish colonial Caribbean
offer us numerous ways of
conceiving of the place of Islam
in the early modern world, and
allow us to see the history
of the Americas in a new way.
And these are gonna be my
closing, my closing thoughts
on these two points.
Columbus's biography with
Islam helps us to see that 1492
was not the break it's
often portrayed to be.
1492, the beginning of the modern world,
1492 the end of the
independence sovereignty
of the Americas.
To properly and fully understand 1492,
we must understand the continuity
that made and shaped it.
Columbus's voyages across the Atlantic
were a direct result of
one particular continuity
that of Muslim Christian
animosity in the Mediterranean.
The crucible of the crusades,
centuries of warfare,
and the increasing encroachment
of the Ottomans west
in the years after 1453 forged
in the minds of Columbus,
Cortés, and thousands of other Europeans
that their enemies were Muslims.
That the notion of enemy to them
had something to do with Islam.
They took this long history
of warring with them
across the Atlantic.
Indeed, many of those
who ended up fighting
the American Indians in the new world
had fought Muslims in the old world.
Some of them would even
come back from the Americas
to fight again against
their Muslim enemies of old.
Cortés, for example, waged
the last war of his life
in Algiers in 1541 after
his exploits in Mexico.
As one of the earliest 16th
century Spanish historians
of the Americas wrote quote,
"The conquest of the Indians
"began after that of
the Moors was completed
"so that the Spaniards would
ever fights the infidels."
Islam had pushed Europe's
crusades to the Caribbean
where even on the other
side of the Atlantic
Europeans still often
conceived of their enemies
as somehow being related to Muslims.
In narratives of 1492 as break,
Islam is always portrayed
as being of the old world,
part of all, that was left behind
for a new European
beginning in a new world.
It is precisely because
Islam was so central
to the history of Europe in the old world
that it had to be excised
from the histories of Europe
in the new world.
Historians have in many
ways followed the lead
of many of these early Europeans
who went to the Americas.
Those who sought to
relegate Islam to the past
in favor of the future free
of this old world menace.
Indeed beginning just a
few decades after Columbus
and continuing for centuries after that,
Europeans feared the transfer
of Islam to the Americas.
Trying to keep Islam out of the new world
meant also trying to keep it
out of many of the narratives
of the making of the
modern world after 1492.
If the Atlantic voyages are so crucial
to the history of the
world after the year 1500,
I think it's hard to argue
that they're not important.
And if Islam is removed from the story,
then Islam is never a
foundational additive
or even relevant to this modern history.
It stands apart, only
appearing every now and then
as a violent enemy on the margins.
Leaving out the story of Islam
in the shaping of Columbus,
thus removes it from the early
history of the colonization
of the Americas.
It prevents us from seeing
the integral role Islam played
in forming the violent early years
of Spanish rule in the new world.
However, if we accept that Islam
is part of one of the
oldest cultural tropes
in the new world, as long as the history
of European colonialism and
disease in the Americas,
if we accept that Islam was
the mold that cast the history
of European racial and ethnic
thinking in the Americas,
as well as the history of warfare
in the Western hemisphere,
then we must admit that
Islam has to be a part
of any understanding of
the history of the Americas
from the very beginning.
The idea of Islam as a deep
existential threat was there
at the beginning of
Europeans stepping foot
on these continents.
The history of this idea
in the Western hemisphere
is older than say Protestantism
or any British or French
interests in the Americas.
It's older than the
transatlantic slave trade.
It's older than any nation
state in the Americas.
It runs through all of
these histories though.
And so beginning a history
of the Americas here
tells very different stories
than those we're used to.
Indeed, we might go so far as to say
that the two origins of
European colonization
in the Americas were it's crusading ethos
of the kind that I've described today
and of course the deadly confrontations
with Native Americans, and
these are linked stories
as I've tried to suggest today.
Telling them together allows us to uncover
a durable conceptual link
in the European turned American psyche
between violence against
Native Americans and Muslims.
If the original language
of European warfare
in this hemisphere derived
from Europe's Wars with Islam,
from at least the 18th century
that language was formed
by America's warfare
against native peoples.
This is a historical reversal
of profound importance that suggests
that we should spend more time recognizing
and thinking about the history
of these seemingly disparate
yet bound cultures.
Moreover, given that since
Vietnam, the primary theater
of American war has been
in the Muslim world,
with the attendant consequences
for Muslim Americans,
it bears thinking deeply about
this long intertwined history
of warfare, animosity and vilification.
So this is admittedly a very long way
from where we've been.
I raise it though because
some of the strands
of our present were spun
by the story of Columbus and
Islam that I presented today.
It's an obvious starting
point for the history
of how European colonialism
affected the Americas.
And I've tried to suggest that
it's also a starting point
for thinking about how native peoples
have been folded in to a long history
of European Islamic relations.
And this is a history I think
we need to assimilate better.
Doing so would help to contribute
to the manifold efforts
to understand histories of
European native encounters
and the histories of European
polities in the Americas,
and then eventually the
United States itself
in a far more global scope.
So I will end there.
Thank you for your attention.
And I really look forward to
your comments and questions.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you, Alan,
for that wonderful talk
and contextualization.
I think there are lots of
questions that we are getting
on the chat, but I'm
burning to ask this question
which is, you know, where do the Jewish,
where does the Jewish expulsion
and where do the Jewish peoples
come in this mix of this encounter?
Do you see them somehow as being a part
or embroiled in this?
And also what I'm really
curious is, you know,
when I want to feel optimistic,
it's hard at the current moment,
given the global alignment
and the sort of animosities,
persistent animosities.
I love how you've drawn,
sort of connected the dots
and shown that these sort of animosity
towards others has a very long history
and a very deep history.
So I was curious, you know,
if you think about Al-Andalus,
right, there was this
moment, golden moment
when these multiple cultures thrived.
So do you, what do you think was key
for that kind of thriving
of these multiple religious
traditions and cultures?
- Thank you for that.
Yeah, so I didn't have time to go into
the history of the Jews of Spain.
It's a really important and
integral part to this story.
I can answer it in a couple of ways.
So one is, you know,
the major events of 1492
related to Iberia are the
Reconquista, Columbus's voyages
and the expulsion of the Jews.
I talked about two of them.
In, you know, there's an
Ottoman part to that story
which is that most of Iberia's
Jews eventually end up in
or more than any other single place,
most of them end up in the Ottoman Empire.
Eventually, this is after
some time in Portugal
or in North Africa or in various
parts of the Mediterranean,
but many eventually make their
way to the Ottoman Empire,
and famously the city
of Salonica Thessaloniki
in today's Greece becomes
the largest Jewish city
in the world.
And at various points
has a Jewish majority,
so the first Jewish majority city--
- Yes, many did go to
Italy as well, right?
- Yes, yes, there are waves of
embarkations and expulsions.
So sometimes people
settle in various places
and then, and stay.
Some people settle for a
little while and then move on.
It's a very complicated, a
very complicated history,
obviously, but in broad brush
strokes, that's part of the,
that's part of the story
that I tell in my book.
And that's part of the story here.
There is a, and of course,
obviously anti-Judaism,
anti-Semitism is rampant in
Spain before this period.
Very famously the, you
know, there instances
of waves of anti-Jewish
violence for centuries,
but increasingly up to 1492.
The sort of Catholic animosity
towards Jews and Muslims
is quite different in its nature.
In the case of Muslims,
it is more geopolitical
and existential.
In the case of Jews, it's more theological
and at the level of notions
of cleanliness, disease,
contagion in cities, right?
And, you know, as I think
you were suggesting,
I mean linking others
to disease is something
that happens in Spain in this period
as it is happening today.
But it's because there's no equivalent
of a Jewish Ottoman Empire.
There is no external Jewish state
that is a potential geopolitical
rival of a Catholic state.
And so that makes the position of,
and there are other reasons
obviously, of Jews and Muslims,
very different in Spain.
So this notion that the Muslims of Spain
are a liable fifth column
for any Muslim polity,
whether it be the Ottomans,
the Mamluks, et cetera,
is one that doesn't exist for Jews.
And so that gives it a very
different positionality
of those communities within Spain.
- Okay, thank you very much.
So I think I'll handle a
couple of the questions,
and Ty, then you can take over.
So yeah, so there's a
question from Carlton Tucker,
besides Marco Polo's writings
and crusades oral stories
would Columbus have possibly
heard of the stories
of Ibn Battuta?
Some have called the Muslim,
referred to him as the Muslim
Columbus a century earlier?
- Yeah, well, the Muslim Marco Polo,
not the Muslim Columbus, but yeah.
I've seen no evidence
that Columbus knew of
Ibn Battuta's writings.
We know that he read various other tales.
For example, the legend
of the seven cities
of Cibola was very important for Columbus
which is a story about, let's
see if I get this right,
a group of bishops who flee Spain
with Muslim ships that have a lot of gold.
They settle on these mythic
islands somewhere in the sea.
And so, you know, various explorers tried
to these islands and the
gold that they possessed,
again to fund a crusade
or for any other purpose,
but I don't think Columbus
knew of Ibn Battuta.
- Ty, did you want to?
- Yes, sure, another question
submitted from a participant.
A few years later Vasco da Gama
is said to have been guided
from the east coast of Africa
to India by Arab sailors.
He found Arab merchants
in India when he landed.
How did he negotiate his relationship
with these Moors in contrast to Columbus?
- That's a good question that I don't,
I don't think I have a, you know,
a full answer to other
than to say, you know,
Vasco da Gama shared in
a language of crusade
as much as any of these other explorers.
He doesn't, yeah,
but that's what I would
answer to that question.
I mean, you know,
Columbus also uses various
Arab sailing technologies
during his voyages.
There's a complicated story
about the kind of sail
that is used on the ships that
he takes across the Atlantic
that combined the technology of the Dhow
which is an Indian ocean
vessel that Vasco da Gama used.
But, you know, in a general way,
Vasco da Gama is steeped
in this same rhetoric,
language and education of
crusade and is seeking, right,
a way around the Muslim
empires of the Middle East
as much as any of these others are.
- There is a question,
regarding Columbus's reasoning,
doesn't the prevailing
current contradict the idea
of wood detritus floating
East to West Africa?
- Okay, I'm sorry.
Could you repeat the question?
- So the question is doesn't
the prevailing current
contradict the idea of wood detritus
floating from East to West Africa?
- Oh, right, right.
I see what you're saying.
I guess it does, but it, yeah,
I think the question
points to the fact that
that notion of of wood
floating from across the ocean
from Asia is wrong.
That wood was probably
coming from the port itself
or from somewhere further
South on the coast
or something like that.
Or maybe it wasn't even
worked by human hands at all,
but when they looked at
it, they thought it was.
Who knows?
- Right, so then there's a question
that is a bit tricky to
parse, but let me try.
So how would you describe
your positionality
or your lens in this research or book?
I don't know if they want you to frame
your political position,
your epistemic position.
- I can answer that question.
I'm happy to answer that question.
So I would say in this talk,
I really turned up the volume
on an idea of civilizational conflict,
one that historians
have generally been
trying to get away from.
And I admit that I wrestled with that,
and I'll tell you a little
bit about why I decided
to keep it, keep that language.
One is that's the language of the sources.
The sources, the Christian
sources and the Muslim sources,
but, you know, focusing here
on Columbus and his writings
and those of others,
they use this language of
civilizational conflict,
of millennial confrontation with Islam.
Columbus spends the last
few years of his life
writing a kind of compendia of ideas
about the end times, right?
He very much is steeped in
this, in this set of ideas
around conquest warfare,
existential crisis of Christianity.
So that's, I'm being true to the sources.
The other sort of historiographical,
I want to say move,
but challenge that I'm putting
forth is the following.
So, you know, historians
of the Mediterranean
and of other cross-cultural
zones, if you like,
but the Mediterranean is the place
where a lot of this work happens,
have over the past few decades
done a lot of really important work
showing how confessional
boundaries might not have been
as fixed as we think.
Linguistic boundaries, you know,
Italian traders were
living and marrying often
in the Ottoman world.
Muslims were in Europe.
There's this sense of back and forth,
almost a kind of happy go
lucky trading identities,
religions, intermarriage,
language, et cetera.
And that is obviously true to a point.
I think we've overemphasized the idea that
and there are all kinds of explanations
for why we've done this,
but we've overemphasized
the idea that something
like religion might not matter
as much as we think it does.
I think religion does matter
quite a lot to these people
in very stark and important ways,
geopolitically,
theologically, existentially.
And so I wanna sort of re-insert that
into the discussion here.
You know, historians have,
and I've taught this work
in my courses, have to great effect used
the records of the inquisition.
You know, obviously a
endeavor of religious violence
to narrate other kinds
of histories, right,
of commerce, of gender
relations, all kinds of things.
And that's very, very useful again.
But I think we have to understand
the confessional structure
in which much of this is taking place,
and Columbus's relationship
with the Muslim world
is one of the ways of doing that.
But it does mean that, you know,
in some ways for provocative purposes
that I've turned up the volume more
on the violent confrontation, warfare,
civilizational crisis.
- Yeah, but I'm curious because,
so that's very interesting,
but do you know that reframing
of the modern conflict
is not particularly productive, right?
So there's Ferguson and these other people
who think, who are framing
the current situation
as a clash of civilizations.
Do you believe that is actually productive
for the modern kind of, you know,
mirroring today's struggle?
- Yeah, yeah, no, no, no.
I mean, and that, and
that's why we as historians
have tended to move away from that.
- [Priya] Right.
- Nevertheless though, I
would push back a little bit
to say, not to you, but to that work,
to say that when you look at
the history of Christianity,
there is an anti-Islamic
thread that runs through
much of it.
- [Priya] Right.
- And it's pretty consistent.
You know, let's say, you know
we can argue about when, and.
- It runs deep.
You're right, it runs very deep.
- It ebbs and flows over time, et cetera.
And I think, I think we
need to wrestle with that
and take that seriously
and understand why that is.
Look, there's been a lot of
work done on antisemitism,
the long history of antisemitism
from antiquity, even
before Christianity, right?
From antiquity to the present.
You know, there's a whole set of books.
There's been some on, you know,
an equivalent sort of story about Islam
in Christian thought, but I
think there's a lot more work
that could be done there.
So yes, I wrestled with
not wanting to tell
the kind of clash of civilization stories
that Muslims and Christians
have been fighting
for all time, everywhere, always,
and yet pretty consistently,
at least from the period
that I know best, right,
the kind of late medieval to the present,
if you look at various
periods of Christian writing
and thought, I'm talking about
European Christianity here,
you do see that there is
a pretty consistent trend
of anti-Muslim sentiments,
writing about the theological
bankruptcy of Islam,
talking about the political
corruption of Islam, et cetera.
So that story needs to be told.
I'm not doing that here,
but that balance has to be kept in play
of not doing the crude version
of clash of civilizations
but nevertheless seeing
that there is a story here.
- Right, so the next question
is from a member of the audience.
What I heard of Muslim
influence on Columbus
is that Muslim sources had the best figure
for the circumference of
the earth to find the Qibla,
but they were expressed in Arab miles
rather than the shorter
Roman miles used in Europe.
Columbus used good figures,
but with the wrong interpretation
to argue that the voyage was shorter.
- Yeah, I mean, I haven't gone deep in
on that line on Columbus.
Look, when you get into
the Columbia scholarship,
it goes in all kinds of directions.
- Right, and there's also issues of maps.
I remember reading that
there were incorrect maps,
that, yeah.
So then the follow-up question is
Genoa had colonies in the
Crimea as you pointed out,
so I'm surprised that there
was such inaccurate information
on the Mongols.
There was no Great Khan by then.
- Well, so the idea of the Great Khan,
many historians think,
is based in some fact
that being the Nestorian
Christians of Western China.
So there is evidence that
during the Yuan period
that there were people who
converted to Christianity
and that that might have been one of,
the reference for the
idea of the Great Khan
having an interest in Christianity.
- So there's an interesting question.
Is there evidence that when
Cortés and others went back
from the Americas that they took with them
some of the people they
had conquered, and if so,
were these individuals distributed
by them in North Africa or in Europe?
- You mean native peoples?
- [Priya] Yeah, native peoples.
- Yeah, yeah, no, native
peoples go back with Columbus
and, you know, after that,
that's a quite common thing
on various European expeditions
for native peoples to go back to Europe,
not back, but go to Europe
and then sometimes back to the Americas,
but sometimes not also.
- Great, Ty, do you see
any further questions?
- No, I don't.
I think we got 'em all.
- [Priya] We got them all.
- [Deepti] Yeah, can I
just follow up my question,
the Cortés question,
about the native people?
So were those people forced to assimilate
into Christianity or Islam or?
- Well, it depends what, you
know, who we're talking about,
because--
- [Deepti] No, since you mentioned
that they were perceived as Muslim.
- Right, no, no, no.
I mean, so usually when
native peoples come,
are brought to Europe,
they are sort of displayed
as spectacles to be seen in cities,
and any kind of religious conversion
that they would have experienced
or had forced upon them was
to Christianity not to Islam.
- [Deepti] Okay, thank you.
- So thank you so much, Alan,
for this wonderful talk and
answering the vigorous Q & A.
And thanks everyone for attending
and look forward to seeing you all
at the next Franke event.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you.